foreign
[Music]
this is enclosure I don't know if we're
in an enclosure or if we need to enclose
something to contain it I'm gonna guess
not that
oh good
oh I am slow
uh-huh
fascinating
a weird walk cycle
uh-huh
is this supposed to be some PT stuff
it is some PT stuff
how very PT of you
what are you doing there trash bag
what are you doing there
fascinating
[Music]
interesting
no trash bag this time
but that's fun it's been a while since I
played anything PT based you know it's
almost to the point where I wish I could
play PT again itself because I've seen
so many clones of it and even to this
day like you know there are some
extremely rare events in there that most
people probably didn't see and or
experience that was kind of the point of
it was that it was supposed to be
different I think anyway
God you threw a bit of a narrative but
but it's the thing where you can't even
download it anymore you know
you can download it oh no there is white
goop on the floor now
oh no someone threw aside the ballot of
wood
sorry
uh sorry all right
I'm numb oh okay
[Laughter]
all right okay all right
oh
no I need to pick that up oh boy oh good
all right then it's been a while since
I've seen the gems get quite like that
strange things happened in our small
town today in the morning hours
said the victim was wrapped in black
plastic cellophane while his head was
found separately near the river where
the old bunker building is located
okay well good thing I'm not an old man
right right everybody right ever what am
I looking at what am I looking at what
am I looking at what am I looking at is
that an old man severed head oh my God
it's huge he had the biggest head I've
ever seen my God that that is a massive
head it's an ogre and head
also not that old I don't think
well anyway I won't worry about that
that didn't match the description at all
the suspect has been apprehended the
young man Andrew Walker is currently
charged with the first degree murdering
battery
was possessed and didn't commit this
horrible crime all right well possessed
you heard the man
oh that's horrible for so many different
reasons why hi hello oh no
all right it's fine then
is that saying behind me how much behind
me yeah how close do I gotta be how
close do I gotta be to read this what
does that say
be Hindi be Hindi yo be Hindi yo behind
you
fine
ah
I'm food sorry
I'm freaking sorry what
oh wait a minute
oh well that's not good I don't know if
that's good guys guys I don't know if
that's good
are you sure that it is you and not
someone else
huh
oh oh am I sure that it's me and not
someone else who am I if me I'm not who
you mean them easy me open the door and
you me but you are you and who are you
you me me you and who you know that you
mean who is
what do you even know that you mean oh
you even think you know what I mean no I
don't know what you mean no
no I'm not me
just for the sake of it while you were
chasing down ghosts and now here we are
the Fallout of your good intentions oh
uh so I made clones of myself just for
the heck of it so I could constantly
walk down sewer hallways
oh okay
oh good
[Music]
the gall of this game the balls on this
game the balls on this game the hood Spa
the hood Spa the hood spot
all right you got it
hi kailulu hi mime
kill him
only way to escape
what if I leave
what if I choose the high road
what happened what a true ending but
what happened I did it I think
I think I did it I think I took the ax
but around just went you know I gotta
give credit to a game that is willing to
do jump scares like that I feel like
games these days just don't do that
anymore because it got made fun of but
you know what it still makes you jump so
there's something to be said about a
good jump scare out of nowhere it's
random and it's it's [__] but it'll
make you jump and frankly hey why not
have a game like that why not do it good
for you game
moving on
welcome to wheat Harvest Paradox sorry
my my face is in the way wheat Harvest
Paradox we are a wheat Harvester look at
the depression
look at it it's raining up
that is sick but also look at the
background of depression anyway
one day a meteorite fell into one of the
poorest cities which mixed two
directions of time this is the usual one
that goes forward in Reverse time
because of this a temporary chain was
formed in which the direction of time
changes every day
what
was that the meteor
oh
I'm alive I'm dead I'm alive I'm dead
wait a minute
oh menu bread water only on normal days
well
good morning combiner or rather evening
cause it's a reverse day I remind you
that at the end of the day you must
exchange the wheat Harvest for our
currency wheat coin
I ain't got none of that
I ain't got none
but uh whatever Mr chefman you're
apparently in charge hey how you doing
there hi it's something wrong with your
leg oh another reverse day we are sure
to survive
what do you mean
seems like it would be a bad day oh good
reverse day hello goodbye don't talk to
me screw you oh wow I don't know about
the architecture I don't know about that
one I don't know hey how are you doing
hmm I managed to come up with a formula
to charge my invention which will break
the time Loop and time will be normal
forever true I need a lot of wheat to
make fuel for my imagined
I hope you can collect so much wheat I
accept wheat in the form of coins I'll
exchange them with the chef later
oh I don't know if that's a lot or a
little bit I don't know
I don't know all right so I have an
objective that's awfully nice
um but also what is happening
oh combiner all hope is in you why one
day we'll get out of here what do you
mean you don't want to talk to me what
are you me with your red flannel and
your Club hands
hi what are you doing here
hi I used to live in a similar hole I
got bored and decided to move now I
regretted it was much better there
unfortunately with me is my faithful
friend goose wow you're right
huh I'm confused but I guess I gotta go
get wheat I don't know what that's gonna
do for all of us or how wheat can be
transformed into time survive this
reverse day I'm thirsty but alas the
rain is going in the opposite direction
can't you just hold your mouth open and
go oh no well I'm crazy okay I'm the
crazy one here all right so uh
do I just go start plucking do I start
oh
ah I see okay
hello I'm a mechanic and I take care of
your combine remember this field as a
reverse copy of you in the combine I can
also upgrade your combine to harvest
faster and better here you can take a
look at the available upgrades I work
for wheat coins there's a reverse copy
of what does that even mean
because this is why I missed just like
playing these because I miss all the
weird like random ass games current
direction of time backwards what does
that mean
I'm harvesting
what
oh
whoa whoa what
whoa
can I back up no only forward
well I mean time is moving backwards uh
well oh my brain guys my brain my brain
is breaking a little bit brain is
smoothing it's in the process of smoking
yeah the smoothenation is happening
let's get all those wrinkles out of
those brains of ours like a bowling ball
in there so there's apparently a reverse
copy of me out here does that mean that
on the opposite side doing the opposite
Cuts is me or what is the deal
because uh that looks like it might be a
reverso but it's just sitting there
oh but I don't want to end the work day
I don't
know what this whole backwards time
nonsense but everyone's still moving
forward nonsense that seems like
nonsense
oh he's walking backwards oh so that is
the backwards all right I'm done
uh so
so what did what wait that's not bad
okay that's that's marginally better
than I thought it was it's still not a
lot do I go to sleep I guess I go to
sleep
so what is it uh I don't need to sleep
right now yeah I do but okay
uh
you don't want to talk to me
is it a reverse day or is it a forward
day and what's the difference what do
they mean
talk to me talk to me where
what does it mean
what does it mean what is it hey wait
the weed's not there wait the wheat's
not there improves the quality of the
cut oh hell yeah oh hell yeah increases
Harvest coverage hell yeah
Smooths movement speed hell yeah Harvest
coverage smile yeah or whatever
I guess I go but
Corrections wait a minute what wait a
minute wait no what what wait a minute
the backwards me wait oh
oh interesting
fascinating
oh
so what happens if I run into my
backwards spanning self
is it gonna be bad is it going to blow
up the universe
I'm going for it
donk oh
what happened
oh what happened
did I run into my backward self was that
bad oh no it's fine it's fine
no it's fine there's no consequences for
that there couldn't possibly be any
consequences for that that would be
ridiculous if there would be any
consequences for that that's not what
we're about here
[Laughter]
How can there be more wheat than when I
started this is so bizarre can I get
over a hundred percent wheat because
that doesn't make any sense God my brain
my brain I have 102 wheat does it make a
lot of sense but that's what I have
pretty soon if I go in like random
chaotic directions like it's just gonna
make me in the future or the past ah God
there I go again me in the future and or
the past just have to dodge my my truck
like a bullet I mean I don't think that
there's any other way to turn this into
an actual horror experience except for
the existential horror kind of
experience but still
this is peculiar all right I'm just
gonna go
I'm done now
I did it
I got a hundred and twenty percent of my
wheat
thanks pal why am I doing this
how am I doing this what was that
ah it's back
I thought those was legs I thought it
was legs oh
I thought it was legs
all right
another backwards day another glorious
Backwards Day
this isn't a horror game don't scare me
all right
let's get quality I guess
quality would make the most sense that's
just going to give me the most in the
long run right and speed
probably I don't know uh current
direction backwards excellent oh God it
is it is just a random Ram I'm just
gonna chase me down
I'm here you come here Slowpoke we gotta
hurry up God damn look at me go
drunk Farmers out here as if you get
drunk and time goes forwards and
backwards you took your drunk and
undrunk and then drunk again and then
undrunk it's been a while since I had a
drink I'm pretty sure that's how it
works right where'd you go me and me's
real [__] look at look at me
hey stop that you I'm also still
wondering where the horror elements is
coming in because this is a horror
horror game I don't know if just
existential dread is gonna be it but I
am farming up a storm so I'm waiting for
the horror
look at me go look at me girl this is
pretty cool
I gotta admit it's pretty cool I'm into
this that's not bad but I'm not gonna go
too much longer I'm not going to fill it
up over 100 again I'm just gonna
make sure that I oh okay bye make sure
that I get a decent amount and then end
the workday probably around 80 percent
or until I get to the end of this line
or I hit myself I'm done I avoided it
nice
hello oh 80 000 that's nice that's some
quality wheat
all right forward day if I do enough I
can get it I think in the next one if I
do like over 120 I'll have enough to
fix everything but I kind of want to see
how much I can upgrade this bad boy
uh
yeah I kind of want to just upgrade it a
lot
I want to get the best I want to I want
to get like the most bitching combine I
possibly could that's what it's all
about right
why else would you do any of this
God I wish I hadn't farmed like this
okay we're fine
all right I think that's enough
how much more of this crap do I need to
do because I mean I don't understand how
weed coin is gonna stop the world but um
let's see what happens
120 000 nice you know I don't think
there's any other upgrades that are
worth getting I'm gonna have all this
anyway
uh yeah I'm fine I just need to get
about 60 to be able to guarantee that I
have enough to
prevent so
a dick bag me who does me think me am
me doesn't know how to drive all right
that's enough
okay I did it I did it Chef here take my
wheat
take it and I sleep and then I go wake
up and I stop time from being backwards
hello fix it
I'm sure this isn't a giant dildo under
a tarp
oh
you made that from wheat what
so we did it I think now I wouldn't say
that was extremely terrifying more of
like a conceptually scary thing but
don't worry lixian made sure that there
was so many jump scares lurking around
every single blade of wheat that you
didn't even know you were so paralyzed
with fear
the whole time right leg skin
all right welcome to Mr Hopps Playhouse
demo three I know I didn't finish Mr
Hopps Playhouse too I know that but I
don't want to not support the developer
because they seem to make some pretty
cool stuff and this one is different
and it's such a such a ripe potential
for stuff here so I'm eager to see what
it's got where am I oh interesting we've
jumped to 3D we've gone from PlayStation
one to PlayStation 2.
interesting
man
you got more of a Vegeta forehead than I
do
where am I oh
fascinating
oh I can move I there's a camera okay so
I can move the camera with my mouse
I thought it was isometric
oh good
oh this is great oh that's normal yeah I
often have torches in my house next to
wooden ceilings and walls
C
I see
just like my house for real for real
oh
I need to get out of here of course I do
I'm much faster than I was hey look
money
sweet nice okay so what do I do to get
out of here and how am I gonna die
hey fruit
I love fruit
I do I miss fruit
you ever just miss fruit God I want to
ride my bike
what Amy Says like no you're hurt
I'm fine my knee's fine my hip is fine
no that's not what he uses it's it's not
Amy at all actually it's my manager so
like no one thinks that Amy's saying
anything like that because that's not
how it is it's my manager my manager and
Evan is just like you're gonna give me a
heart attack keep riding that bike don't
you ever ride it again I'm like I'm
gonna ride my bike I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do it all the time and then it's
just like that's literally a quote from
Evan is you're gonna give me a heart
attack on that bike my God and I'm like
I love my bike you can't stop me just
try to stop me from riding my bicycle
it's my bicycle and I'm gonna ride it
forever and ever and ever I'm gonna keep
writing it you can't make me not ride it
oh I should have paid attention to that
map over there
all right so either that's the beginning
or the end
um I'm gonna guess it's the end but I
know the pattern now
okay I'll try the other way
hey whoa whoa whoa hey
stop
what
hmm interesting
what did I do
money
perfect
key not as ideal as money
wait a minute wait ever wait wait
a minute
please tell me someone else saw that am
I crazy am I crazy am I crazy that was
like a stab to my soul like the spike of
adrenaline because like my brain wasn't
sure what it saw
what in the hell I think it was Mr hopp
looking around a corner I'm pretty sure
but I can't say for certain
oh God
okay whatever it's fine hey a plant
oh that's normal
yeah that's normal
good
uh
I don't know why but the Aesthetics of
this remind me of a game uh from way way
long ago it was like a doom type game
I had like a magic wand she can never
know the truth ah man I can't remember
it all so long ago
okay
do I move this Barrel
ah
easy Quest
easy this was like a Dos game I played
it when I was maybe like three or four I
was just like super young it was it was
in the same era as like Doom I think it
came after
um
god what the frick was it I don't know
it was spooky it scared me as a kid it
probably wouldn't at all now but it
scared the crap out of me as a kid don't
know why
nightmare 3D
was that it why does that sound so
familiar it was Nightmare 3D holy crap
how did you know that
oh my God that yeah this game scared the
crap out of me see this this doesn't
look like much of anything right this
game scared the [__] out of me when I
was a kid it was one of the earliest
like it's not even a horror game but
that's it scared the crap out of me it
looked a bit like Doom it's just like it
just terrified me I don't know what the
deal was
ah anyway sorry I'm back into this game
where am I
piano
okay
[Music]
I don't know if I'm supposed to do
something with that
a lot of curtains in this place money
oh my God what the hell oh Pit of Doom
okay
well this house seems awfully strange
I don't know why any of this like this
I don't know how I got here I don't know
how
whoa okay it's not there anymore
[Music]
all right great this was her favorite
song she has terrible taste in music
more incredible but maybe that was one
of you guys's favorite songs I don't
know
hello
[Music]
why why are you doing this to me why
giant hole hop out of there I dare you
there you
dare you I don't know why I'm collecting
money I don't know why money is a
necessity here but
I don't feel like I have bigger concerns
then why oh hold on a second what okay
yeah I know I need to duck ha ha
good great
too smart for you money
more money why money
why
was that only did I just did I just do
that to get money
loots more money
I like money
[Music]
oh
God
oh is this a no I thought that might
have been a door
okay
there's that thing again and this is
just
oh like it won't even let me do I go
back I don't think I can go back can I
no I can't there's got to be something
here that I can do with it I can't go in
the chasm it's not like I'm gonna throw
my money down into the middle okay
there's no secret there I just gotta
feel like there's something else here
through this puzzle because why why
would it just be this
see I can't go Aaron anywhere else so
this is literally it
so unless there's something that I'm
missing which there might be
but I feel like I've gone everywhere
right
plank in room there's a plank in the
room there's a plank in the bedroom is
there a blank in the bed I thought that
wait wait no way no way
joking me
gotta be blasting my ass there's no way
huh that's impossible
nice try heretic
there's no oh that ah that didn't look
like a plank that looked like a pillar
because everything's wood
oh I've got this
now there's nothing that can stop me I
know that lexian is gonna edit that and
make me look good right
good
great whatever you're saying I love it
you could be saying anything at all and
I absolutely 100 believe in whatever
you're saying and endorse it fully
ow
okay I'm okay
I'm all right
Black Lands manner
[Music]
have I heard that name before I don't
know have I
have I
uh
uh I don't like you
I don't like you God
I don't like you at all
oh and ho ho ho ho
hey that's what you're gonna call me
screw you
screw everything of you
call me a hoe
oh
good one of these again
oh nice
okay
oh God it happened again
okay what just exploded did something
explode
why did everything Shake
it's weird
what's with this
I don't like this
this does not bode well
why does that not bode well that doesn't
bode well
okay
it's been a while since anything's
what
oh
oh yeah that's fine
oh that's normal
what
oh that's probably not what I should do
oh God what is this what is this
nonsense I don't know what any of this
is
foreign
oh my God oh my God
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute oh this ain't right
this is not right
okay okay
well that's bad
um oh
please oh you you oh don't do it no I'm
not here I'm not here I'm not here I
don't know what you're supposed to be
I'm gonna run by you oh no don't spare
me
why are you doing this you're not Mr hop
you'll never be Mr hopp
Ed okay
so there's got to be something that
could tell me what the whoa there's got
to be something that can tell me what
that is all about because I don't know
what that is she had been chosen well
good for her
what about me and you better not be
talking about me because that wasn't my
favorite song okay
there might have been a clue in there
that told me what I need to do to get
the other things there but I don't have
time to go well I don't like that
well that was fine good great where are
you going where are you going
oh hop hop hop oh I see okay eyeball
pistol shrimp okay got it eyeball
pistol shrimp got it
eyeball
pistol shrimp everybody understood
[Music]
I don't know
eyeball
pistol shrimp got it understood good
can we need to eyeball there's eyeball
and then remember the next one a pistol
shrimp
all right here we go
there we have it all right I bet that
unlocked the cage for the key and the oh
that's a problem don't do it
uh you oh he's crying cause he couldn't
get me oh shut up what's this do
[Music]
hell yeah
was this four I don't know maybe I'll
beat the stairs
almost got spliced in half
must be here yes
oh
[Music]
oh oh hey wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute you don't want to do this
hop Hopman hopping popping no hopping
please don't happen no
I'm in no hey happy man happy man
well it didn't run the right way that's
for damn sure oh I'm I'm a girl
you'll never catch me Hopman you can't
catch that which has no soul
just try try and catch me up man you'll
never do it you'll never succeed I am
beyond speed
I am beyond everything
I have seen universes Beyond you are you
still there you still there okay I guess
all right fine
is that gonna stay down yeah dude
fascinating
hop up
well Harper
you're gonna Hop On Pop Into Your Grave
kind of the worst I'm not good at that
trash talking is not my specialty
but who needs trash talk when you can
walk Beyond
the universe it's less that I'm moving
that I'm moving the entire house around
me
oh
I did it
what did I do
did I open the way
excellent
this looks just like my home
ah
what a nice little bunny statue
adorable
oh
credible
a nice glass
uh good Arts
time for sleep
nope
well
interesting
ah oh oh that's not good this poor girl
is tied up ah yep I see that
well nothing to be done about that I'm
the float on elsewhere
okay
well there you have it Mr Hopps
Playhouse three just the demo what seems
so always happened is these demos come
out and people were like oh great game
good boy nah it was just a demo I
haven't played Mr Ops Playhouse number
two all the way through I played the
demo that and then I meant to get around
to the full game and then I couldn't uh
I'll get there eventually but that was
pretty good I did enjoy that a lot
[Music]
foreign